I'm going to Disneyland.
Come and join me there.
Are you ready for some fun?
Disneyland is a magical place, full of wonderful characters.
Look, there are some now!
Can you name all of the characters in this photograph?
Try your best.
I see Donald Duck, Mickey Mouse,...
...Minnie Mouse, Goofy, Pluto and the Chipmunks.
They are standing outside of Sleeping Beauty's Castle.
Wow, it is a big castle!
I want to go on some of the rides and roller coasters.
They are exciting!
Don't be scared, come join me.
Let's walk around and visit all the sites at Disneyland.
Are you hungry?
Me, too.
Hurry, let's buy some food and get ready to watch the big parade.
Wave to Mickey Mouse!
Hurray!